les fantômes sont réels à ce point je sais
bien que la romance gothique est une très belle
chaîne qui mélange le noir et le
beau donc c'est surtout un
film axé sur les personnages qui fait peur mais
ce n'est pas une hormone Je joue Thomas Sharpe
qui est un gentleman anglais venant en
Amérique  et c'est un rêveur et il a un
charisme et un charme et un mystère à
son sujet c'est le grand inconnu sombre dont
le personnage de Mia tombe amoureux puis
elle se rend très vite compte que derrière son
charme se cache un passé beaucoup plus sombre Je joue Edith
Cushing c'est une jeune  écrivain, elle est très
ambitieuse et fougueuse et assez naïve,
ce qui finit par faire partie de sa
chute et elle nous trouve en espérant que c'est
une relation très dangereuse et doit en
quelque sorte trouver son chemin il a fallu
huit ans pour faire le film nous passons un
longtemps à écrire mais longtemps à
concevoir le film pour que les visuels
ne soient pas seulement beaux comme je peux être
ce qu'ils ont raconté l'histoire comme je protéine
il a juste l'imagination la plus incroyable
est si riche quiconque a
vu le labyrinthe de pan quiconque a vu
The Devil's Backbone sait qu'il
est capable de trouver de la beauté dans l'ombre
, c'est une personne tellement merveilleuse et crée
un monde fantastique et oui c'était
incroyable de pouvoir habiter
ça  Tommy est un acteur adorable et
incroyable et il apporte de l'émotion
et de l'empathie au personnage de Thomas
Sharpe et Mia est une fille qui est à
la fois très moderne et très intemporelle
et antique elle a apporté de l'intelligence et de la
force au personnage de soit je
pense qu'elle est  Honnêtement, l'une des
actrices naturelles les plus douées
avec qui j'ai jamais travaillé, elle est si puissante et si
forte, c'est toujours agréable de travailler
avec des personnes que vous connaissez d'une
expérience précédente et nous avons de très
bons rapports, donc c'était génial et c'est un
acteur fantastique bien avalé par son
jeune a
dit je suis heureux de présenter un film bas
vient et prends trois le labo Le Mans
là-bas gamma da da ensemble sur hormone
gothique cadre est wop démo s  etting
this 12 the Phantom male a phantom saw
this on blam demo enter d la film a calm
in patio a solenn beaucoup I'm muzu